Fonzworth the correct
I thank you everybody for coming to this
boot camp lecture so this is about the
geometric complexity theory program on
the introductory or bootcamp level and
everything is always over the fields of
the ground field here is is always the
complex numbers do I have several
advantages where I not go into that as
several advantages at different points
and and the polynomials that we discuss
are mostly homogeneous polynomials so
because also there several advantages to
that so homogeneous several things also
work for non homogeneous polynomials but
let's just keep it simple and let me
also mention that we do have a given
with Marco's blazer together I've given
lectures on introduction to geometric
complexity theory at silent university
and there we have lecture notes now and
you can download them they're freely
available and so the stuff is all
covered in the lecture notes in quite
some detail so the lecture notes
and those we actually had computers so
computer science master students
attending this course has no problem
might soul
all right so the yes that's you google
my name and then my website has a right
so so the computation model for today's
algebraic branching programs and it's a
very specific version of those are to
break branching programs it's the one so
you have a directed acyclic graph more
s2t right and and and the graph is has a
single source single sink and is layered
so there's you have these layers and
each edge only goes from a layer I to a
layer I plus one no no no edges so
there's nothing that skips a layer and
each edge here is labeled by some
homogeneous linear form so there's this
labels le for each edge and they are
some elements of some homogeneous linear
polynomial so say we have M variables
and this all linear polynomials okay but
there's no constants here that's the
important thing
so therefore this always right that's
that's that's a computation one will
always compute so what does it compute
the computation works as follows you
compute the sum over all as t paths and
take the products over all the edges of
of the path so you take a product of
homogeneous linear forms and say if the
depth here is d so then you will always
compute a homogeneous degree D
polynomial in this way no other thing
that you can compute and yeah you can
define now so yeah every homogeneous
polynomial you can obviously you can
compute it in this way if it's
homogeneous of degree D you just to
every monomial gets a single path right
and you can define now what is the AVP
complexity of your polynomial is now the
number of required vertices that you
need to compute your polynomial all
right
police are just the homogenous linear
functions yes Linea they are not so
there's no constants it's not X plus 1
or X something it just could be
something like X plus y or something
like this but no no constants here so
therefore everything so whatever they
just computes is therefore homogenius I
just to make things a bit simpler it
would be a so the setup will be a bit
simpler and ok so now you can define VBP
this is iso without a me so that's the
sauce friction that we only compute
homogeneous put in limits but this is
VBP the homogeneous polynomial version
right so you would take the class of
sequences while the algebraic branching
program complexity is polynomially
bounded I know this is your so class VBP
or sometimes called the debt or VPS so
be PWS Santos or different names for
this class okay so that's our
computational model on the one side and
here and you have the permanent on the
other side this is for y non polynomial
so yes yeah it's non uniform it's a non
uniform model of computation exactly
yeah and the number of edges could be
larger but surely you're not worried
about polynomial factors I'm not worried
about polynomial factors I'm not worried
about any puranam effectors anywhere at
this point yeah so it's a bit onion so
the issue is so the yeah so there are
several ways of getting polynomial
equivalent computational models and so
we are still searching for the one that
is most suitable for a DCT approach
alright so and at that point you might
as well just take some polynomial blow
up and this one is this one is it seems
like it is a suitable model of
computation where some issues that
happened before whether with a
determinant was permanent they don't
happen in this in this setup so this is
a seems like a cleaner setup because
also because everything's so much genius
yeah but I don't worry about like
polynomial blow ups so you could you
could insist for example on every layer
having the same number of vertices if
you want to they get some little blow-up
that would maybe even be cleaner
circuits beyond just completeness some
yes yes it is it has a relationship so
you can define this class also as the
class of of circuits that have a skew
circuit complexity that's pretty nobody
bounded and the service queue of all the
product gates just have a variable as an
input or you can also say as weekly few
circuits where you have an each product
gate you have a independent sub circuit
coming from at least one side in
particular this has polynomial size
circuits yes in particular suppose but
so this is the determinant is complete
for this class it's the class for which
the determinant is complete you can say
you can take that definition but we
don't know if the determinant is
complete for VP all right but there so
there's close connections to circuit
size the exponential there yes the
number yes that is so the number of
paths can be expression but that's a
very bad way of writing this very no
mayor that's inefficient yes this is
like multiplying V matrices it's a yes
it's a it's the you take you take these
matrices here those are rectangular
matrices with homogeneous linear forms
you multiply them you get a at the end
you have a one by one matrix that entry
is your is your poly no way that you
compute
and that that you can do efficiently as
you want to put what you want to compute
this side the permanent right so
permanent is this polynomial here we
know this as a sum over all permutations
of M symbols right and then you take the
product off with the Exide by o5 now you
have this double indexed variable soit
so you have yeah so now your M Squared
when you variables so this is how much
genius of degree M is this say in this
model and yeah so you can define any M a
this is a shortcut you can define a
permanent or complexity also and that
one is the smallest n such that your
polynomial P can be written as a
permanent of some matrix and the entries
here are now a fine linear so I put an
example here so we have some polynomial
you want to compute it say this is your
x squared plus XY plus X plus 3y you
want to compute it say as some permanent
so you have it as a 2x2 permanent here
so therefore and and now your entries
are f fine actually
and therefore the parametric complexity
here is at most two okay that's that's a
but that's now a measure where you can
easy quickly define vnp or I didn't know
if EMP is now class of sequences of
polynomials where you have a polynomial
a bounded permanently complexity okay so
this is this big conjecture from 1979
yeah one has shorter yeah you can make
it there so you should make this
homogeneous then so then you can compare
vp v b pn to the entry else ooh yes
and just to make sure so you can
actually have homogeneous polynomials of
degree D which have further to
complexity which is larger then D Oh
I would think so yes what I said that
should not yeah so should not capture or
pronoun bit sequences okay there's a V V
P is not equal to v NP that's the
conjecture okay so and this is a say now
we take homogenius here so to make this
formally correct this let's just say
homogeneous polynomials now it has to be
permanent over have fun yeah it has to
be permanent over finances true it is
yes so if you come up with a nicer
homogeneous way of phrasing with the V
and B I would actually be appreciated
all right so this is an F I model it but
you want to compute I'm a genius
polynomials v NP also are several
definitions of course but they are all
there tend to be a fine
I don't have I don't have deep insights
as to why you need everything is just be
deeper lovers are teary deeper
permanence of the DVD matrices yeah yeah
I mean he'll you need have fun of course
otherwise you only get you everything
will be homogeneous of your permanent
degree so that's not what you want yeah
so
some can be 0 yes 0 no because you won't
get those turns only get you get imagine
as degree TR 0 polynomials so okay open
question is to give a proper homogeneous
definition of the NPS could you is it
possible to do it where the you either
have pure degree 1 terms or constants as
possible yes that works you can do that
if you want to that's the more classical
definition no no no it does not
guarantee homogeneous and Suki you can
even do variables or constants if you
want to that's variance classical
definition you do vary variables or
constants it's also not homogeneous but
here this is actually not such a big
problem because the because we can
revise this okay we can phrase this
properly so this conjecture here now as
you see this is phrased in a bit of
weird way because the VMP doesn't have
such a nice definition but there is an
equivalent way of phrasing this and
there everything is nice here and it's
this way here is the sequence AVP
complexity of the parent is not
polynomially bounded and now
everything's nice it's an equivalent
conjecture and it doesn't involve any F
finest anymore we're well into summer
genius this is a homogeneous model of
computation now now I have things clean
right
our complexity EVP complexity is not a
subscript as a little C I mean yes or
notation might might improve over the
time I guess yeah open for I'm a very
open for suggestions so every
computation model you get some new
complexity and they have to have some
name all right so there's so there's
another mm you can you can trace this
also in a slightly different way if you
if you don't want a bps and if you don't
want to have the this model of
computation there's another homogeneous
model of computation there's a second
one which is you take the instead of the
instead of a product of matrices of
homogeneous linear forms you take a
power of one matrix I take the trace of
that or the one one entry of that and
those are all possible models of
computation that are homogeneous and you
can use them in a completely equivalent
way here and you want to compute the
permanent but also all models that you
could use and this one seems to be seems
to be the nicest for reasons I might I
might touch on okay so okay we so GCT
now tries to prove this I mean so there
are several setups and so on this is
this is one set up it's not in the
original papers but it's a it's pretty
close to this so you want to show that
this is not polynomially bounded right
and but there are some issues with this
and and the issues are best explained
and also the approach is best explained
when we switch to a much simpler
computational model that's also
homogenius okay and that's the warring
ring that's a classical notion I think
first papers 1851 by Sylvester and and
it's the following on ocean so it's also
model of computation so you have some
polynomial it's all my genius of degree
D and you want to compute it but you
want to compute it as a linear
combination of powers of homogeneous
linear forms a very simple form of
circuits and that's called the warring
rank or symmetric rank sometimes code
and so the minimum n such that you got
these homogeneous linear polynomials and
some
coefficients so that you can write your
polynomial as a linear combination of
these powers of these homogeneous linear
forms alright so this is an example here
say you want to compute 6x squared Y oh
yeah you can decompose it into these
linear combination of three cubes so the
rank for
6x squared Y is almost 3 and what you
also see so you observe let me put this
here maybe in between that if you have a
nonzero scalar and then the warring rank
of your polynomial is equal to the
warring rank of our scalar multiple of
the polynomial so you can just rescale
it doesn't matter what and so this is an
this is something that will happen more
often where you have some some way of
modifying your polynomial and your
complexity will not change all right so
this is also a one example of a group
action of okay so but this is already
pretty nice so in particular one sees
now the wall rank of x squared Y expert
is at most three right and this is all
right this is also always finite so it's
a proper model of computation so you can
you have a say you have a product of
homogeneous linear forms this could be
any monomial say then there's a formula
here is codfish's formula sometimes that
expresses this monomial here as a linear
combination of powers of these powers of
homogeneous linear polynomials it's not
so important how this looks like it's a
2 to the D minus 1 summons
there's some sign issues here and then
yeah and then you get exactly yamanami
all right so you do this for every
monomial and this this proves that this
is always a finite model of computation
just use some complexity right so boring
right
alright so let me um so this is very old
study prior to break geometers and so
and if you study this then a lot of
things happen that also happened if you
study the algebraic branching for
complexity so in particular the
following happens so say you're you are
looking at x squared Y and
it's yeah so that's a decomposition here
telling you that x squared Y has a
warming of at most three but you can
also show that the Waring rank of the
Waring rank is actually three so I don't
want to go into that now you can use
some computer algebra system or some
other methods for this and and compute
this so now some interesting thing
happened is that if you look at the
following decomposition you have X plus
epsilon Y well it's one of your cubes
and you think of epsilon as some little
some some some small number okay and you
subtract the second cube so that's now a
war and we're going to write and okay so
that's what I'm going to you can plug it
actually everything for upside on at
this point but now you don't want to
allow everything for epsilon anymore you
divide this by 3 epsilon now you cannot
plug in epsilon equals 0 anymore because
yeah this is not defined and but but
what happens is yeah so here let's us
expand this so there's X cube is
canceling all right and then we get
three terms still so this is X square Y
and side on X Y squared and you get a 1
over 3 epsilon squared Y squared okay -
I cubed - all right
and now so that you now let epsilon go
to 0 and this converges to x squared Y
all right but this all right so what do
I mean by this convergence here it
converges coefficient wise Weiss will
you look at polynomials always you start
with so we study polynomials as a list
of their coefficients and since we are
only working here in a finite
dimensional vector space or we fix the
number of variables we fix the degrees
of a finite dimensional vector space of
polynomials and we can therefore we have
a natural way of having a Euclidean
distance and we can just
convergence thing like this so this
converges to x / y and this this says
that in the limit the wall in rank can
grow alright so this was the source of
water wrong like to put in um it's
always a curve actually so if you look
at this picture here there's a warning
of of polynomials at most 1 the set and
that's this bigger set of polynomials of
where I get most 2 and then there's even
bigger of where I won't get mostly and
now there's expert wise sitting here at
the boundary
there's expert why because it has a
going rank of 3 right but it can be
approximated arbitrary closely here from
from the inside and this is what happens
right and now intuitively if you want to
prove a lower bond that the wine rack is
3 then intuitively this should be very
difficult because this is a business
opportunity close to being a boring run
- yeah and indeed yeah indeed you can
now I mean so for more can make this
formula so wise it's not difficult to
prove this because there's no if you if
you're searching for function f say
you're searching for a function f that
vanishes on the set of Waring ranked at
most two polynomials
it should be always 0 here and you want
this F to be nonzero at your point say X
square at x squared Y you ever have it
knows you're something like this so I
just like a separating function you're
searching for this then such a
separating function cannot be continuous
right because if it's continuous it will
be zero there so there's no continuous
function doing this but but several
lower bound techniques in algebra
complexity theory they do use continuous
functions for separation right so for
example a method of shifted partial
derivatives does this and so you can
never prove so there's a bound that you
can never prove with these methods so
what people do on algebraic geometers
did and since they do want to separate
everything with polynomial is indeed yes
yes is it possible to have a function
with walk with whirring mom or ignite
can't eat which is a path which is
approached by functions and rankling
twine at one 9 k bias to avoid more or
less yeah so okay so the picture is a
bit misleading so the the gap doesn't
have to be always 1 but it could be the
case that that picture the bubbles lie
in a different way and a more
complicated way so you have something
like this something exists right below
could be looking like this all right
yeah so the gap might be higher yes
thank you
and indeed we don't know actually how
large this gap can be sorry
yeah bones they are both I think it's
exponential bounce unknown on that but I
think that is all there is so I actually
do want to post this as an open question
so what let me do okay let me define now
this notion of border warring rank and
and the gap and we want and yeah and and
the gap is the open question so how are
large campus gap is the border warring
rank so we define
before a warning link is so usually
these are covered you just put an
underscore so then you have a border
complexity measure and so this should be
the smallest and such that P can be
approximated arbitrary closely by by
some P epsilon and the warring rank of
the upside on is it more than okay so
that's border warring rank and the
example here the border warring rank of
X square y is it's just two and you
always have the border warring rank over
any P is always less or equal to the
warrior and copy
well the question is how large is this
gap right and this is an open question
that is very much sure yeah that's a
sext year let me yeah okay let me post
this properly so you define a complexity
class of say for you see sequences that
have a polynomially bounded wrong rank
and then you have the others complexity
class of polynomially bounded pour avoir
rank and we do not know is also the same
so that's already this is already very
embarrassing so this has been actually
asked by micro forbes in 2016 already
um yes you'll be polynomially bounded
yes yes yes
so let's say yeah let's say V W so we
vwy rank P maybe so they were most
branching program so let's just do
something like this
yeah class yeah say number of X so we
say P families right so this is always
when we look at just says that number of
variables is polynomially bounded degree
is polynomially bounded also okay let's
just let's just say degree and number of
variables is polynomially bounded as
usually called a pea family all right
and then of P families with what you
normally bound it warring rank and yeah
so in its closure this is also you can
always define for I will come back to
class and algebraic one you can
obviously find its closure should be the
same definition but then you have a
bottom measuring out so the question is
are those the same on this that's been
progress partial progress in this
direction but it seems it seems that is
this non-trivial
there in any bounty Porter or is there
any family yes I think so
I would have to look it up exactly but
there are some some singly exponent
should bounce on the gap yes yes that's
all fine so suppose you got two
polynomials P and Q then have very
different warning right yes and then you
so before this that seems that yeah most
of the time we would probably be high if
there are no cancellations but I mean
you can always drop in I mean in the
limit it can always drop that happens
for matrices if you have matrices that
have a rink and you have and you ensure
that epsilon goes you and your matrices
I mean your rank might drop arbitrarily
in some big way or in the limits which I
asked the question just because you said
the gap between 2 and 3 and then but it
can't go up in the limit it can go up in
the limit so this is this is yes it's
going up in the limit and now yeah and
you are having something where it's
going down in the limit so I think if
you want to come up for the separation
you have to fix the epsilon in your
example whereas you want to show that
these separations are showing but I can
takes epsilon smaller and smaller so
what you're showing is just a sequence
of polynomials where the limit is got
small border complex areas on this thing
but we really are looking at a single
Parliament which okay maybe this is
something I'm missing itself so
so I mean when you were describing
people of epsilon times Q minus P you
have to fix an epsilon to give me a
candidate counter example to some
separation once you fix that epsilon I
mean it's no longer going to zero right
so whereas in these in these things when
you're trying to prove the water rank of
some P is small then after you given the
PE
Christiansburg pick epsilon smaller and
smaller and smaller and getting closer
and closer approximations
all right and now
and you can do the same thing or for
branching programs and so GCT does this
implicitly a lot I mean a soul is
implicit so you you would define we
don't know those well so I would have I
would have to look up the reference for
that one so i i i have i have a pc
student who sent me a reference about
this one but i would have to look up
which one what was the precise reference
so now obviously we define a MEP
complexity bar right and and then
therefore VBP bar all right as
polynomially bounded mep complexity and
all the conjecture is and the system
more like sony conjecture but also
appeared actually in a very similar way
and Burgesses work and the same year in
a similar fashion
so yeah it's both us not that explicit
anyway so so the conjecture states that
that you would have v NP should not be a
proper subset of V P P bar or
equivalently you would have that you can
also phrase it as the NP bar is not
equal to VV p bar or you can search also
say because yeah
maybe we don't like v NP or you can say
in a very nice homogeneous way sequence
of Exodus they say AVP complexity bar of
the permanent the sequence is not
polynomially bounded and everything is
nice and homogeneous that's the
conjecture and now this is a different
conjecture implies the variants
conjecture right and big open question
right so let me also post this
explicitly it's a big open question is
these two conjectures are the same and
is this equivalent to variance
conjecture and yeah so yeah this is also
it's obvious that one should probably
solve this one first here and because
then I can work on this one because if
you don't understand this I think hope
is very small that we can settle this
one yes yes I can yes so okay I can do
that so it's in color here so if you
want to define AVP underscore bar
it's AVP complexity bar it's the
smallest wrench as you P can be
approximate a very closely where there's
some AVP complexity that's bounded by n
that's the IVP complexity bar and VBP
bar is now the vp bar is now it's a set
of P family so set of
versus 40 no myths party nominee about
it Amy
he collects the underscore that one and
and without the closure it was just I be
PC and now it's a PC on the score
so when you say values conjectured you
don't mean the P versus BMP you know I
mean the PS vs v NP yes yes I mean the
paper the 1979 paper is not very
explicit about the precise conjecture
so yeah it's the VPS versus VMP yeah so
the V bps exactly the bps is not known
to be the executive VP it's not known to
be exactly like that one can also set up
all these things in VP but it yeah it
seems to not look as nice and so even
even just the problem with what a
complete polynomials right might be the
same yes yeah might be the same anyway
this is the easier conjecture then it's
easier than
all right so about this question there
is some progress on this there is some
summary some things that point towards
this could be true and some things
pointed towards this might not be true
so I want to give you the parsha
progress on this one so there's three
results on this and one is non
commutative it's a non commutative
version where this works
that's a that's a paper by Noemi son in
1991 and was pointed out by a
microphones that this works 16 as saying
that you can define it so let's let's
assume that our variables all do not
commute
all right so therefore we compute in our
computational model now homogeneous
polynomials of non commuting variables
and defined exit everything in exactly
the same way so let's define a non
commutative an alternate version should
be a non commutative ABP complexity and
non compute if a VP complexity
underscore and you can define both of
these in exactly this is completely
unethical okay
and now the theorem that unison proofs
so there's a corollary of his study of
non commutative may be peace and so
these are the same if you are careful
setting up the AVP p-- definition
properly then it happens that these are
precisely the same complexities so the
proof so this one is always less than
equal to that one and the proof that he
gives is that if you if you have a if
you have a lower bound on that one you
want to show that that's also lower more
on this one and so he takes the he takes
the lower one here and he show us that
you can always be proof by by a
separating polynomial so he explicitly
even constructs the separating
polynomial so which is a polynomial
that's 0 on all low complexity points
and a polynomial that's 0 on all please
he proved that whenever you have a lower
bound right so then then there is just
putting omit vanishing on all low
complexity points but not vanishing on
your point I saw and he proves that this
always exists but if there is such a
polynomial then you also get a lower
bound on the on the border complexity
because that polynomial also vanishes on
the border so he X the [ __ ] this is a
very explicit construction that he gives
there
so when you say this all of the managers
on these things that the pallava takes
us and put the coefficients of this is
yes yes and it's just a regular complex
for Louisville I mean now yes it is a it
is actually is a determinant of it's a
determinant of a matrix yeah it's a sub
determinant of some matrix that you
constructs yes as a regular polynomial
yes
but it's on on this space of non
commutative but the polynomial is
commutative it's a regular commuter
polynomial in s that is what he
constructs so which is yeah that's
that's nice I mean it seems like this
would be here I mean gives hope for this
so I thought this might be this thing
and and that's not another thing where
this that gives hope but this one should
be true this is for matrix
multiplication so yeah so warring rank
yeah this too so commutative seems more
complicated yeah this is an exact
equality that even if you change the
definition of your every piece a bit it
actually doesn't work anymore
yeah so one finds things in the boundary
pretty quickly if you Essos not very
this is not very robust
yes matrix rank is also is true for
matrix doing this is also true yes good
so there's more evidence that the stupid
su well never I mean so let's be careful
maybe so for matrix multiplication so
you can define matrix multiplication in
terms of warring rank or so so let's do
this so I define a matrix multiplication
polynomial it's a cubic polynomial and
so some goes from ijk 1 up to M and this
is a product of X IJ times xj k times xk
i okay that's a cubic polynomial so
degree three
as quadratically many variables as
degree three
so you can define what is the you can
define the metric certification exponent
actually using this polynomial so you
can say Omega is the limit so usually
you have just the in but here for this
definition we need to limit usually you
so usually you take a non commutative
version of this and then it's different
various but you can so that's a paper
let me put this may be so this is so you
can use this formulation and there just
been in a recent paper that we published
so she can t need and how Einstein in
Landsberg and tota Vianney so this is so
you can use the following definition of
Omega so it's nothing nothing very deep
if you you have the classical
definitions then this is actually not so
it's hard to see
you can use this you can take the Waring
rank of this polynomial and and you take
the logarithm and you change that would
be Omega and now that's a result that
beanie from 1980 that you can also do
border warring on and also gives you
Omega so this is BS result 1980 in a
different language though but but
basically this is basically his resort
where you take the logarithm of the
border waring rank verification
polynomial also also gives hope that
this might be true right but on the
other hand one has to see that this is
just homogeneous of degree three
all right so that's the subtleties come
into play when you get some higher
degree side when Omega is the matrix
multiplication exponent right so if the
exponent that you would have when you go
the runtime exponent for the multiplying
to M by M matrices
all right all right yes so it could be
quadratic polynomials to keep the point
okay so I did not I I did not give the
proof of this fact that this is Omega
okay I did not give the fact so what you
do it so what you get is if you do
matrix if you look at my certification
you usually get an order three tensor
out of that because yeah by lineae maps
are that's a vector space isomorphism
between a set of bilinear maps where the
matrix multiplication is a point in and
the set of order three ten source you
have to input spaces in one output space
and it's a bilinear map so you get an
order three tensor and that's the
Scimitar ization of that okay matrix
modification normally has m squared for
long is that you want to compute which
are of degree two and somehow this is a
way of folding these m square things
into a single trap degree three cancer
okay all right so that's it
yeah but that is okay is this not true
is a non-trivial step to see that this
is true but so once but when you coming
from where you know that Omega can be
described as the rank of our order 310
so then this is when there is not a
large step to go from there okay but you
have to what one has to I su get there
so by linear map saw and order 310 sauce
also or the same thing and there's one
yeah so that but that's also negative a
negative example here the girls are
being reused right there various out
being used yes none okay it's not
trivial yeah you need something don't
need a little construction so you lose
it constant yeah so you lose a constant
factor because your embed this in some
larger matrices yes it could in the
other X I Y and see that's your useless
it's also true yeah you get it also yes
it's also true this is also a I mean
this is this is very robust yes Omega is
pretty robust done or whatever you want
to do there yes all right and there's a
negative answer so you can define what
is the continuing polynomial tensor at
some exponent sake Robert watt why was
it warning R and not some a BP subject
other thing well that's because of the
so yeah no it is just because a set of
researchers is interested in warring
wing alright so that is why this is the
formulation there are several equivalent
forms so you can make it so the paper
here is about how to rewrite Omega in
different forms so that you get a a
format where you can study it in symbol
cases so on for matrix for the matrix
ratification 10 so already the three-way
which case was very difficult to study
and so this version here
you lose I want the on the one hand you
lose some constant factor in your
algorithms but on the other hand you do
that you get the possibility to study
this in small cases and so you can do
three and four and things like this
right and so there are yeah so there are
even you can restrict this even further
so that yeah so the paper has yeah not
it's it's about warring rank but of
special types of matrices or traceless
matrices and things like this could be
more specific than that so I go even
further and further and and so the hope
was that one see somehow from this first
examples one can deduce maybe
decompositions of the tensor that was
that was the idea that this warring rank
as within a constant factor well that's
a four basically in between yeah
constant factor of four yes actually yes
so 2 to the 3 minus 1 for Fisher's
formula is the 4 right in this case so
there's there's a negative answer though
to this also which yeah
so this sheds a bit negative light on
this and you can define what is the
continuant as you define it as follows
here's a polynomial so that should be
should be um a degree is non-homogeneous
put you know we're here that you define
in this recursive way
so we define a zero being one okay one
being x1 and km should just be km n is 2
plus xn K n minus 1 all right so this
gives you some kind of people not she
like recursion and you can define now
this is a polynomial and you can define
the continuance of complexity because
it's also polynomial I want to do that
maybe continue enter when you call the
Cirque cc of P so you but here you have
to do you have to solve this this is the
NFI inversion all right so you have to
be able to put in not homogeneous linear
forms but you have to because the
polynomial itself is not homogeneous you
have to put in some math find forms
otherwise it's not going to work well
you can define this and you can also
define in the in the same way CC bar
polynomial and it's known that there's a
huge gap between the two which yeah so
this is a large gap between the two so
that's a huge because
CC of P and CC are P and the reason is a
bit M yeah it's an interesting one but
it's also a bit too simple reason that's
there's not not every polynomial can be
computed so not every program it has a
finite cc but every polynomial has a
finite CC bar alright so that's a recent
paper by M so we saw those texts you to
results so the one result is called
corollary by a paper by Ln down one and
and the that the CC bar is positive it's
always finite it's a is a reserved word
ringman so item SEC bar is also is the
same as the as up to polynomial factors
this is the border formula size of your
polynomial is defined in one sequence of
polynomials there works the way so sorry
this is like the determinant of
complexity so the terminator complex you
write everything as as a determinant and
the entries are defined in your forms
and here's the same so you've write
everything as continuent but now the
variables you replace by a friend in
your forms and you compute some
polynomial in this way yes you can now
put yeah you instead of X and you put
any f-find in your form and you compute
some polynomial in this way n minus 2 n
minus 1 the indices are fixed time
that's it's not even in disease that's
the definition of this polynomial here
that's that's this is the polynomials
call to continue and so you get it you
get to continue and also as a as a
determinant so you get it as a
determinant of of a special so this is a
special type of determinants of
complexity where you put ones here
and now you have to use F Vanya in this
version you have to use f1 yes so this
is an F I inversion here so the
determinant of complexity also is an
affine version and this is special case
of that it's also an affine version yeah
it's not so nice of a version right it's
an F I'm very but here this gap is huge
because this is here CeCe's might be
infinite
this can be infinite
and actually that's a small example of
this is infinite and this is always
finite so this is a bit don't panic
something maybe so that I mean
expressing this Turin in this way makes
nicer senses I mean you could pick any
polynomial you know family of
polynomials in defining this you know a
similar thing here
si si doesn't always exist and it
wouldn't always exist for other
polynomial system why why this one okay
so yes okay let me say that so if you
have so the class of polynomially
bounded so P families the paper has
actually the following with right so
class of
P families of polynomially bounded CC
bar that's equal to a class that's
called d PE bar and that's it's not
exactly VP VBP so for vbp you take this
branching promise here you only take
formulas with a polynomial size formulas
and constant fennan alright additions
and multiplications and you have
constant value so this is a so therefore
this class here is a so this so CC bar
gives you a natural class here it turns
out that CC doesn't right
but CC bar gives you a natural class
that's that's been studied here there's
the P bar
all right so this is open right so we
don't know so what does then so what's
the deal with his border complexity and
so why do we actually do this so is
there any advantage of having all this
pain and comparing these measures and
they are surveys and and so the reason
why we do this is because once we once
we go to this border complex see we've
we find that that we can that the sets
of complexity so let's just do this so
let so maybe I wanted to find a
complexity see could either be the
warring rank or you can take out the
complexities if you want to maybe AVP
complexity and now you want to look at
the set you study the set of polynomials
that have a where the C bar of P is
bounded by n okay this is some fixed n
you just look at this set is a set so a
fixed number of areas to pick some
degree everything is fixed and this lies
here in some vector space and is closed
under taking limits right so that is
stores and I take a limit so you can in
a different way you could write this as
P whether C of P is less than equal to n
so when you take the closure right so
this is the same and so therefore what
is nice now about this set and and its
structure that it's closed is that you
can always separate it with a continuous
function right so you have some point
that doesn't lie in the set you find
some continuous function that vanishes
on the set it will not vanish on your
point right so you there is such a
function it's the distance function to
the set say right so that's easy and so
but now we have additional structure
actually on this set so and so one can
prove that the set is actually an
algebraic variety alright so let's just
define this quickly
maybe yeah before the break then we
define this fix both the division yeah
everything fix yeah so fixed fixed
number of variables
it's not a fixed degree that's fixed and
yeah now you want to look at this set
yeah so nothing's growing or anything
everything's just fixed finite and now
you have a variety so so you
therefore you are now living in some
vector space so everything is now in a
vector space of yeah of some so well we
are actually in this vector space here
let's say we have M variables now we are
homogeneous of degree D okay and I just
call this vector space maybe see area
the vector space of coefficients now
that release these have and so if we
have a subset here in a C to the ADA
this is a squad an algebraic variety if
it's a Commons you set of polynomials
so I got somebody no meds here f 1 up to
FK and such that X is the set of all the
points where F 1 of the point up to FK
of the point is you let me give you an
example of what's happening here so if
you look at a very tiny case yeah so we
can do this before the break so a very
tiny case so you look at two variables
and degree 2 so you have her yeah so you
so everybody Norman isn't written in
this form is always ax squared plus BX Y
plus cy squared all right it's always in
this one and now you're looking at the
set of one ranked one so not every
polynomial has worn rank one well
usually if we know we would have a
warlike of two but so there's the set of
warring when one party Rome is if you
look at the P by the warring I guess one
that's precisely the vanishing set so
this is a set of P or where where the b
squared minus 4ac is 0 so those points P
piece this is P P is always written in
this form and this is your usual
discriminant right so this is a
polynomial
as a polynomial in the coefficients and
and you can describe warning being one
precise yes the B squared minus four is
sees you so that you may so usually from
yeah you probably know I mean if you
remember if we will remember high school
you know from high school that b square
minus 4ac determines if you've got a
double root right so this is precisely
what's happening if this is a double
root then warring length is one because
warring like one just means that your
polynomial can be written as a linear
polynomial squared so there's two
factors that are the same all right so
this polynomial here is now what I want
to call this F here right so this is
this is in the our case would be an
example of F and in this case it's a
very simple example because there's a
single example here there's a single app
so in particular if you want to prove
that the warning actually does boy make
a border where I'm like doesn't matter
it's the same here if you want to prove
a little bond you just take them take P
Square minus 4 AC and check if it's
nonzero so for example you can show that
the warring link or say bought a warning
of x times y that's bigger than 1 so you
prove a lower bound and why how do we
prove this so you just prove you plug it
in I mean you just take X this is B is 1
a and C are 0 then B squared is 1
alright so what so that your
discriminant is 1 right and what is
nonzero so therefore the you got a
little point now and and so on the point
is we can do this this set up we can do
this actually for much more complicated
sets so warring rank being any bound and
also IVP complexity and the holes so the
whole story were always working you will
always find these these polynomials here
that separate yeah okay so that's the
first part
there exists f1k yeah oh yeah so those
are exact so those are polynomials in
the coefficients okay so those are
polynomials and here in in eight are
many variables okay just put in aa meter
in a debería bits and so in our case it
will also be the case that we can assume
that those polynomials will be
homogeneous so this B Square minus 4 AC
is actually homogeneous of degree 2 and
we can always we'll be able to assume
this always in our cases okay more
questions before we go to the back end
this proof that it's an algebraic
variety does it follow from the fact
that if you're considering going round
one then you get an algebraic variety
and then that is the secant variety of
that variety yeah you can you could yeah
it's something exactly because it's the
sum of those you and you I mean so what
you do you take yeah I think yes you can
you can you can probably you don't to
see like that but you can't yeah this
doesn't work anymore for the more
complicated settings so I sketch the
proof after the break oh yeah of why
this is true alright because this is I
mean this is very powerful of obviously
because now you can separate with
polynomials right okay but this is is
break time now I guess
[Applause]